we've talked a lot about in the past
about the different work you've had to
do getting started in the business I
know that you had to do a lot of stunt
work yeah one of your first projects
right yeah my one of my first projects
was called shotgun love dolls yeah wait
for it and my name was at a movie it was
a pilot ad pilot that never went what my
name is Brock my name was rock candy in
charge of weapons and demolition there
was passionfruit and there was coffee
bean oh so it was like a Charlie's
Angels
yeah was a Charlie's Angels and shortest
shorts ever I don't know why they'd even
call it a thong and then we had to put
wires inside of it and hide the wires
and then get hoisted up and oh so you
were in short shorts and then flying
around yeah you could why I can fly oh
sorry that's a special smell Oh God
evens it out I know so what's that is
that is that cool though it was it so
it's it looks really cool but it's one
of those things where you go wow I don't
know that I'll be able to have kids
after this because my vajayjay is
completely squashed and it was a
terrifying experience it is not
comfortable no we had another actress on
the show not long ago who also had to be
hoisted and her main complaint was that
it's very uncomfortable in that area
pinchy itchy
yeah very pinchy right Chafee yeah I
mean it's weird cuz it sounds erotic to
me I just had an immediate as I would
like to be hoisted right now
just to feel down there again but it's
great birth control
oh yeah you do that for a while but it's
nice but there was nothing nothing like
that in rampage right there was there
was actually they didn't put you in the
wire again no did they did I had to go
in the wire again again and I won't give
away too much because it'll give away
what happens in the film but it was one
of those moments again I was up on a
wire and you know it's a terrible
feeling but I they took a video of it
and I brought it home to my son and
showed my son and he's five it was like
that's what you get to do at work and I
have to go to school you get to fly and
I get to go count numbers right like
yeah yeah but but you know and how do
you explain that you can't yeah I don't
let my children know what I do okay they
really do they think I'm in real estate
cuz I don't want them to know the idiocy
that I'd love to you here at work I'm
like you've got to study Latin what are
you doing tomorrow I don't know
and you're not gonna talk about farting
you